Hello everyone, welcome to the first
video of this channel. This is Jyn from
Next Level Commander and today we are
talking about the most difficult
commander I've ever built. Not since
Time Spyro have we had a commander that
works against you every step of the way.
Generally in commander games, you have
three opponents, but today we are not
just playing against our opponents, but
also this big idiot, Flops the Fool.
Yes, we are playing against our own
commander. And here's some live footage
to show you how.
I need to play smaller
spells. Ooh, I need more land drops. Oh,
look. I can play four lands a turn. Now
I'm
down.
Draw. I need to get alive. So yeah, as
you can see, after jumping through the
first hoops and having a rough deck
together, I realized that Flubs is
designed in a way that gets you stuck
every other turn because you turn
through your spells and the next turn
comes, you realize, "Oh, lookie, look. I
have two cards in my hand. Now what? And
say if I'm lucky, I have a flashback
spell or something I I can use to go
back to the sweet spot of having one
card in hand. I'll be on two again the
next
turn. So, at first I was annoyed at how
the designers didn't see this problem,
right? Flubs really needed you skip your
draw step for it to work as intended, I
thought. But then it hit me. This is the
flavor of
flubs. Getting lost and hitting the dead
end every turn. And I have to say the
gameplay experience captured this
perfectly. Honestly, if this was
intentional, I'm happy for the
designers, but not for me because holy
crap, that's a lot of hoops I have to
jump through. But hey, once you do, the
payoffs is worth it, right? Right. We'll
see. So, first of all, we have to accept
that we are not playing big spells. Not
that it's impossible, but to maximize
flips, if you draw a six or seven drop
early game, your entire turn is
basically over. Even four or five drops
can feel clunky at times. And the next
problem we have to deal with is lands.
If we want to turn through spell after
spell, two lands a turn simply isn't
enough. In the mid game, ideally you'd
want three to four lands a turn. And the
best name was for that. I'm sure you're
familiar with exploration atusa oracle
case of the locked hop house, dried of
theian grove. Now the dried is nice for
fixing while wayward sort and druid
class you can probably replace with any
extra land enabler really. Uh, the life
gain from the class is nice though.
Also, abundance, which isn't an extra
land drop spell, but it's like one of
the best cards in the deck because it
serves the same purpose, allowing us to
get exactly what we need and never be
stuck with more lands than we can
play. So, with that settled, oh yeah, we
still have to deal with the backing
ourselves into a corner. So, with our
brilliant commander, remember every turn
we're going to start with two cards in
hand, which means we have to figure out
ways to draw a card or play a spell or
play a land from not our hand to break
that flop's lock. And here are some
allstars to help us with that problem.
Since it's a mini top, not too much to
say here. Just a ridiculous, ridiculous
magic card. Play with it here and you'll
see. I even slotted in an Öza saga just
to search for it. Try not to take too
long with it though. That's one problem
with this deck is taking long turns. We
want to minimize that as much as
possible. And next we have Obero. This
single best land in the deck. This
combined with the extra land drops makes
it so that you will never never be
stuck. Embrace the Unknown. Another
semi-permanent solution to our problem.
A bit expensive at three mana, but just
cast it once a turn from your hand or
graveyard. And we're set for the turn.
Velica Exploration. Another card that
feels tailor made for this deck. Breaks
the lock and deal some damage to our
opponents. Why not? Year. Now this one
you have to be careful with. It's
extremely powerful. It can easily exile
something like 30 to 40 cards a turn.
And if you're playing Stormman, you can
win on the spot, sure, but otherwise it
might be going a bit too aggressive.
Dreamscape artist, a gem from Planer
Chaos. This allows us to discard a card
to ramp and for the net mana cost of one
because the two lands enter untapped,
which is extremely efficient. Although
for the artist, I had to up the basic
land count in my deck from three to
seven, which is a bit of a downside, I
think, because the deck is extremely
color intensive because you never know
what color spell you're going to draw
next, right? But overall, I think it's
worth it. It's a great card. Fortune
Tellers Talon is chosen because of the
low initial cost. You can just drop it
and playing from the top with reduced
cost can allow you to turn through your
deck extremely fast. It's like another
flux. and Oracle of Modia and the case.
Like we mentioned earlier, they also
serve dual purpose here because playing
lands from the talk can also help us
break the lock. There are also a few
lands here that can allow us to crack
and draw cards and they can help us get
unstuck in a pitch. And last but not
least, we have Song of Creation. This
card just does everything. It's like a
better version of our commander.
Honestly, if this was a legendary
creature, Flaps will have no chance.
Now, from my experience, even all this
isn't enough. with the strategy you end
up choosing, you will need to find cars
that help us break the flops lock, even
just once. And you will see some
examples later. But yeah, for now, we
are done with the flops package. No
matter what strategy we end up playing,
we're going to need a package like this.
It may vary a bit again depending on
what you're doing, but for the most
part, it should be quite similar. Okay,
around 20 cards in and we finally dealt
with our commander and we can kick back
and reload. Oh yeah, we still have three
opponents. Hey, but this is the fun
part. With the flops package in place,
we can now choose our strategy. And this
is where we make all that hard work
worthwhile because with flops, you can
do pretty much anything you want as long
as you keep the mana relatively low.
Landfall is by far the most popular
choice since, well, our package is
already doing that. Flops can definitely
lead a powerful landfall deck. I've also
seen some cool storm builds, but if you
want something a little bit different, a
little bit more interesting, flops can
be an excellent slimes against humanity
commander. Three mana is a bit high, but
just throw in some of the cost reducers
and we're set. And toss in some enablers
and payoffs and we have a slime stack. I
think this is what I'll try once I'm
bored of the current build, which I'll
reveal soon, I promise. And you can do
the same with Dragon's Approach. Only
issue here is we won't be playing a lot
of the big dragons, but rather we went
through Dragon's Approach damage and
speller damage. But of course, there are
a few dragons that are too good to not
play, like Twinflame Tyrant and Miz.
maybe another one or two of your
favorites, but we do have to keep the
count low. And if you don't want to
waste the dragon's approach, search
trigger, there are dragons that you can
cast for cheap one way or the other, and
those won't clock up your hand. So, as
you can see, the possibilities are
endless. Goblins, burn spells, whatever
lowcost strategy you want to try, flops,
and the package will enable. But for me,
I decided to go with a slightly
different theme,
removals. Now, there are a few reasons
for that. First, I don't usually play a
lot of removals and I get criticized
rightly for being too greedy with my
deck building. And second, my group kind
of does the same, too. We have a removal
light meta. And now more and more we are
seeing easily interactable threats take
over the game, unanswered. So, I'm
looking to bring back the interactive
game. And what's a better way to do that
than a deck with over 30 spot removals.
The plan here is that once we're set up
with some of our fluffs enablers, we are
going to chain removal after removal
after removal after removal to keep the
opponent's board clear. Now, let's go
over some removal spells. First, we have
the aforementioned lock breakers with
mechanics like aftermath, flashback,
harmonize, and adventure. We can save
these spells for later when we need
another cast trigger. Meanwhile, the
kicked option for into the royal and
blink of an eye can also help
occasionally. For rest of the removals,
we are going for cheap as we want to
chain through as many of them as
possible in a turn. And versatility is
also important as we might actually run
out of targets as possible. Oh, and if
you care about game changers, psychonic
rift doesn't really need to be in here.
It's rarely overloaded. It did save me a
few times, but not often. And here we
are prioritizing instance and sorceries
to synergize with our win conditions,
which we'll go over next. For winning,
we have the typical spell slinger
package, fire incription, gunner snipe,
cruscation mage, as I like the option to
drop it early for two mana, and
etherflux reservoir isn't quite as
reliable for killing, but the light gang
is delicious. Meanwhile, Sorcerer's
class abilities just synergize
beautifully with the deck, and it is
what kills our opponents the fastest.
Lastly, we also have a land in Field of
the Dead, which can reliably pump out
three to five zombies a turn from very
early on in the game, cuz we get to
seven lands fast. Now, we might need a
few more win conditions, but we don't
really want to draw them early. So,
currently I'm sitting at seven, but this
can definitely be adjusted based on what
you think. And after that, we have some
miscellaneous enablers. Just some random
good stuff. Noxious Revival, for
example, is nice for the free mana cost
and being able to bring back important
pieces or just a little quick graveyard.
Mythical and world leader are nice for
the cheap cost again. And if I need,
they can get MDFC lance onto the top of
library. But again, if you care about
game changers, these are not important
at all. Actually, this deck can easily
qualify for bracket one. Technically,
Field of the Dead is maybe the only one
that's difficult to cut, but is not key
to our strategy, and replacing it with
another landfall token maker shouldn't
hurt too much. And finally, let's take a
look at the lands of this deck that
haven't been shown yet. Some of our
favorite lands in this deck are the
MDFC's. They can be spellouts or lands,
whichever one we need at the moment. And
many of them are actually removals, too.
Now outside of that, we are prioritizing
mana fixing even at the cost of some
life. And there you have it, the deck
with the biggest idiot in magic at the
helm. And the commander is pretty dumb,
too. Now, keep in mind, whatever
approach you end up going with, playing
your deck one card at a time with no
chance to plan your moves ahead is not
easy. I'd recommend this for more
experienced Magic players. And even
then, please make sure to practice
goldfish the deck a fair bit to avoid
making 20-minute turns in real games.
And if you do, please don't point your
friends to this video. I don't want more
reports than likes for my first ever
video. Please, no. But hey, not being
able to respond and plan out your turns
does have upsides, though. When it's not
your turn, you can just leave. Oh, you
know, just kick back and relax and have
some small talk to distract your
opponents into misplaying or stare into
the distance. Heck, you can even bring a
sleeping mask. Take a 10 to 15 minute
power nap between turns. The
possibilities are endless. So, yeah.
Thank you. Thank you. This is our guide
to flubs. Thank you for watching my
first ever video. My next video will be
about decks that are built solely around
the commander and why I think it's
actually the best way to approach our
format. It should drop exactly 7 days
from now or from when this is posted.
But yeah, I will see you again.